I'm starting off this morning by by
playing a game of musical chairs I don't
hear any music but uh
anyway my name is Wayne McDonald I am
the chairman of the Health and Human
Services committee and elderly Affairs
Committee in the house and I've been
appointed as all of us have to this
committee and I would uh like to welcome
you all here and um I believe it would
be a pro oh okay and at this point uh I
who would
okay
so uh I see that on the the agenda
so I would uh certainly welcome any
okay
would a sign up sheet be appropriate to
pass around
okay
um representative King could you pass
could you do you have any do you have a
good
I just want to pass about a sign up
sheet for everyone so that we can we can
record who's here
representative Weber has won so we'll
pass that around
I am advised that we do have a quorum
um so with that uh as that's going
around let us proceed to uh the nominee
and now the uh
choice of our offices and I'll open the
floor for nominations for chairman of
the committee of the oversight committee
Mr chairman yes this is representative
Merchant uh thank you for convening us
today
I would like to place into nomination as
the chair representative Pearson
thank you is there a second to that
nomination
nominations when made by Senator by
representative Merchant seconded by
representative Weber are there any other
nominations
if not I will close nominations and um I
guess it would be appropriate well all
those in favor of Representative Mark
Pearson please signify by saying aye aye
opposed nay motion carries
congratulations Mr chairman
the chair wishes to nominate
Wayne McDonald as Vice chair
is that a great second to everyone
thank you representative McDonald is
Chairman of the best Committee in the
house Health and Human Services
and spent many years working at the
chair wishes to appoint
um representative King as Clerk and
representative King at some point would
you find an assistant Clerk of your
choosing I like to do that I do that in
my children and family law I did that
last time in Health and Human Services
not only does it give a backstop in case
somebody's absent a backstop who is
trained who knows the job it also means
if we go at a terribly fast pace and
we're out speaking someone's ability to
write there is somebody right there in
place
uh Senator great to your knowledge uh
who are the other Senators
um
according to the list online it's uh
myself Cindy Rosenwald and Senator Kevin
avard
thank you and um
attorney William Hughes
Tony Williams you've said that uh
Senator avard was was not aware of his
appointment until just recently
and and Senator Rosenwald had a
oh okay she let me know that she would
not be able to be here today so it's an
thank you senator
I think we can pass that down to the
clerk
you should have before you the draft
minutes of the November 18th regular
meeting you should have been sent that
ahead of time but you should have a copy
of it remember when it comes to minutes
we don't update in other words if
something said in the minutes and events
proceed we don't correct the minutes
this the minutes are corrected for
accuracy as of when the meeting took
place so please check them over and see
if anything in here is wrong
Mr Mr chair yes sir a small detail uh
under the absences uh I I was absent I'm
not listed I considered an excused
absent I was at legislative training
away from the building
sew up at the top under absence absent
please put representative Edwards
second
okay so moved by Senator gray and
seconded by representative Merchant
Edwards Edwards
if I have a point of order the minutes
with the
change at the top for absent point of
order representative Merchant thank you
Mr
um given the fact that I wasn't here for
the November meeting should I be
abstaining or
what action can I take on these minutes
probably abstaining because you would
have no way of knowing one of the other
Senator gray
um Robert's Rules would allow you to to
the best of your knowledge that this is
what happened I don't know whether this
committee is operating under Roberts
says the Senate does or under their own
rules so but
and house rules generally don't allow
abstentions so you're stuck in a
quandary and I think people have done it
both ways in the past in the committee
as many of you know my style here is try
to build consensus and I think in my two
years tearing before we only ever voted
once and I'm really not sure this is
going to make much of a difference so
whatever
which is kind of Pearson's rules
okay any other Corrections that need to
be made we'll give you another minute or
so
and Mr chair I just want to remind you I
have to step out at 10 43 for another
meeting at exactly 10 43 with military
Precision yep thank you
and I know representative Merchant has
are we ready on the minutes okay all in
favor
I opposed see that's the workaround it's
a Voice vote we don't know how you voted
okay
actually I wasn't here then either so
this is true
I was and I still don't remember it so
uh just a little for those of you who
are new here how we usually
um have our meetings usually they are on
the fourth Friday of the month at 10
o'clock
on occasion when that's a holiday
weekend it is moved to the third Friday
at and it has been at one because a
couple of members have a morning event
on the third Friday so count on unless
there is a change count on the fourth
Friday we'll be meeting on the fourth
Friday of February at 10 o'clock
what usually happens here besides the
roll call and the approval of the
minutes is
um
we have a wonderful event that I
nicknamed learning from Laurie
and that was when Laurie shiban at the
commissioner would come in and give us
an update I saw no reason to change the
title so we will start with learning
from Lori and that may go for oh some of
us hope quite a long time we'll see but
she is the interim commissioner then
after that different
different reports are given if you
remember when we vote on bills it will
say such and such a committee is
established and they are to make an
annual report to the HHS oversight so we
will hear numbers of those reports
and then the final thing that can take
place is something special something
particular that is to say
we are wondering about something at DHHS
and so we would like to bring in an
individual to talk to us about that or
sometimes somebody over there it's not a
regular report but there's something
they'd like us to know and they get on
the agenda so if there's something you
would like to know about let me know and
we will make sure that we schedule this
for an upcoming meeting
so that's kind of what we do here any
seeing none
learning from Lori we welcome
interim commissioner Lori Weaver
good morning thank you I was waiting for
a question if there would be CEUs given
out after learning with Lori I assume
that
thank you thank you for the opportunity
I am Lori Weaver the interim
commissioner for the Department just a
little bit about myself I have been with
the department for 25 years uh
in different roles last three years as
the Deputy Commissioner prior to that an
associate commissioner and prior to that
and various director roles within the
department so I'd like to think that I
know the department fairly well however
in the last six weeks I've learned a lot
of things that I already didn't know and
I've been there a really long time so
I'm learning as well
learning with Lori that's right I
thought for this morning the update
would probably be most appropriate to
sort of lay out for you some of my
vision for the upcoming year as interim
you know there's never any guarantees of
how long I'll be in this role but I will
just look forward to the year and set
some goals and benchmarks and I wanted
to share with you today what what we
were looking at doing and and part of it
is not being able to do a strategic plan
in the year is really challenging but
what can we do and we can do some
planning so I will be introducing to the
organization I haven't fully done it yet
it's coming up next week talking to all
of the staff
what I'm calling a road map a 2023
roadmap for HHS
so it's basically a high level plan that
we are going to put forth four
commitments within the department that
we are intentionally focusing on and
will guide all of our work against
and hold ourselves accountable to those
uh commitments over the upcoming year we
will be sharing progress with this
committee with fiscal committee with any
other committee as appropriate as well
as external stakeholders how we're doing
and where we may need to be improving so
at a high level I can share with you our
commitments there's four of them and the
first one really is investing in our
Workforce and our culture just like many
other sectors we are hurting from a lack
of staff so I really want to focus on
building up that Workforce
not only hiring people but also
increasing retention rates why why do
people stay getting them to stay and
then obviously working in our culture so
we'll be spending
um quite a bit of time on
on that setting some goals for what
where do we want to be at the end of
this year
the one of the second uh commitments
is uh managing our resources effectively
and efficiently and this is really about
aligning up all of our internal
operational pieces so that we don't have
a lot of duplication and to ensure that
the resources that we do have are
targeted on the things that are
priorities for us so as you probably
know the department is really large and
we have a lot of things happening all of
the time and if we could align and
strategically
resource those uh
resources appropriate those resources to
the priorities I'd like to be able to
see us get farther along in this
upcoming year so that's really if you
think about a project governance
structure it's really our leadership
looking at everything that comes in from
above below and from side is this
something the Department's going to do
we need to see how it aligns with our
priorities and do we have the resources
to do it at least for this first 12
months and kind of hand in glove with
that is what we call enhancing
organizational value
so for what we are doing how well are we
doing it so it's really about metrics
and it's really about
um working with our partners to make
sure that what we spend our money on and
what we're attending intending for an
outcome or service what population are
we trying to help is that contract or
that service showing us those results
and if not how do we align that so we
don't get to the point where we've
contracted and spent a lot of money but
we don't have the results so we're
really going to be focusing in our
division of
quality assurance to hone in on that
and then our fourth commitment is
internally related but it's also
externally related and we call it
promoting thriving communities and
that's really about looking at making
sure for those services that it's the
right service for the right individual
at the right time
so you might say well what does that
mean well we could look at initiatives
like our children's system of care model
we know that we spent a good amount of
time and money building up that
infrastructure and we have it but we
also know that our utilization is low
because we don't have staff in those
programs to staff it so we have children
backing up in hospitals that could be
discharged but they don't have a place
to go so it's really looking at that as
well as like Juvenile Justice
transformation and moving to a
restorative model rather than a punitive
model so there's a couple other pieces
in that but my promise to you would be
that once I have all of those goals and
as identified and outcomes I will be
sharing that with you I just I need to
share with my organization my Workforce
first and that's coming up in the next
two weeks and this was developed just so
to just to bring Clarity uh this this
was in terms of my vision of what I was
seeing in the 12 months that we needed
to do I engaged all of my leadership
team to weigh in and help with that as
well as the boots on the ground the
people that are going to be doing this
work so that's what taking that's where
at the point now finalizing all that and
getting ready to launch it so I thought
that was probably helpful for an update
it is very helpful thank you and uh
councilor Williams
do you have those handy sheets that you
know I love so much that is the names
and positions and phone numbers and
everything
okay and you can bring some hard copies
at the end of the month if you would
please
It's a Wonderful sheet it's it tells us
who all the division heads department
heads are and about I want 80 85 percent
of them come under your committee and
the other 15 percent children and family
come under that committee which I chair
so it's a good who do I call listing if
you don't have one you're going to get
one very soon I I thank you uh Tony
Williams did give us
sorry I think that Tony Williams did
give the at our um
orientation meeting I remember correctly
a similar sheet didn't show attorney
Williams
I think you did at that time at the
other committee good
for those of you who lose things while
standing still such as me
um it's good to have a few extra copies
around I've photocopied six of them I
can find four of them I'm proud of
myself
how many people named Lori are left at
DHHS the new popular name is Melissa it
is no longer Lori well I you know I said
to Mr lippman you know you're always
thank you we'll look forward to updates
next on the list is the child fatality
Review Committee annual report the chair
recognizes
Trish Tilly
good to see you again director of Public
Health good morning good morning chair
good morning graduate of Hampshire
College I am indeed thank you good
morning it's great to be here thank you
so much
um so I am just going to give a couple
of brief introductory remarks and then
actually bring the people who actually
do the work to present the reform our
New Hampshire child fatality review has
been around for decades um with the
purpose to identify and collect data
about the cause and Manner of Child
deaths and importantly to provide
prevention recommendations based on that
data in New Hampshire right now just I'm
going to cut to the Chase and tell you
that the top five causes of
unintentional deaths among children and
that is age one zero to 21 include
overdose deaths accidents from ATVs and
snowmobiles motor vehicle accidents
accidents drowning and blunt for ours
trauma equally concerning is that
suicide is by far the leading cause of
intentional deaths suicides by hanging
suicides by Firearms suicides by
poisonings between 2017 and 2021 there
were 93 suicides of Youth up to age 21.
each of them heartbreaking each of them
leaving a family in grief so before I
hand this over to the team that put this
report together there's three reasons
why I think that this report is
important one it's powerful it's data
driven and I think members of your
policy and finance committees you know
it gives you the information that you
need as you think about your own
priorities and as you think about policy
setting for the entire state
number two the focus is on prevention
while we are lucky that New Hampshire's
child mortality rate is well below the
national average one preventable death
is too many so this is um
we understand deeply that one grieving
family is too many and three this report
is a reflection of partnership it is not
the Department's report this is the
report of a committed group of
community-based individuals doctors
epidemiologists health behavioral health
specialists on and on prevention folks
they have all reviewed this data and
they have had robust conversations about
what we can do better
everyone on the review panel is
committed to the notion that preventable
child death is a collective problem and
that Solutions can be found in the
community as well as in our homes so I'm
going to hand it over to Rhonda Siegel
Mark Clement and Joe Porter and they're
going to walk you through the report if
if I may
thank you you may thank you
question from representative Edwards
good morning good morning you know I
can't let you get away without at least
one question right
um so uh I I I skipped ahead I I the
recommendations pages on six and seven
sing to me what would make it really
great is to know is there a specific
recommendation where you think
legislative action is required and can
we highlight the recommendations with
for which you would expect some
legislative support it's that is a great
question
um and it's a great idea so when the
group when the committee and they can
talk more about it the chairs of the
committee put together those
recommendations I think they can speak
to whether or not they feel like some of
those rise to the level of policy
interventions right now many of the
recommendations are really
community-based recommendations there
are things we can do now things we can
do with our partners but I'd love for
the um two chairs of the committee to
weigh in on that and take that as a note
for the next time we prepare the report
to be able to highlight that right up
front
representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um I'm assuming intentional you
mentioned intentional death I'm assuming
that the great majority would be suicide
yes 88 of the intentional deaths are
suicide the others are homicide I was
going to say so the other bucket is
basically homicides and that's that was
what I was going to get at the number I
wasn't really aware of how many
homicides 12 percent as you're saying
yeah it's just about 12 I'm sure I don't
have the report I didn't bring the
report up with me to give you the exact
number but
um by far again suicide is the leader of
the intentional but we have had
homicides in that age group from 0 to
21.
it's very concerning wow thank you yeah
thank you all right so I will hand it
over to this group thank you
and they are aware that we're supposed
Mr chair just so you know there's a
significant number of people out in the
audience that are going to want to go
down to division three at 11 A.M that
that's that's I think do they want to go
are they just going no they've been
compelling compelled yeah they looked
and would you uh give us your names
um good morning I'm Rhonda Stegall could
you spell that please excuse me could
you spell that sure Ronda r h o n d a
uh Siegel
[Music]
s-i-e-g-e-l thank you and then I'll
that my colleagues tell you their names
and then I'll
good morning I'm Joe Porter I'm with the
University of New Hampshire and I'm a
co-chair of the child fatality Review
Committee Joe
Porta Porter p-o-r-t-e-r oh well all
right back
I'm also co-chair my name is Mark Marc
thank you good morning
um it's nice to be here again my name is
Rhonda Siegel and I'm the section chief
for maternal and child health within the
division of Public Health Services under
which the administration of the child
fatality Review Committee and its two
subcommittees stunning unexpected infant
death review and the sudden death
um in in the young review reside we
actually just came right now a sewage
combined suet sdy meeting is taking
place
um RSA
established a child fatality Review
Committee whose function is to answer
the following two questions what could
have been changed that would have
prevented the death
and what changes are necessary to
prevent future deaths
so for Steward and sdy we review all
deaths in a state however that's not the
case for child deaths we select cases
Based on data Trends as presented in the
report and we work hand in hand with the
office of the chief medical examiner who
is our is a vital partner
um for State fiscal year 22 which this
report is about in the larger child
fatality Review Committee we focused on
suicide and motor vehicle deaths
um we reviewed eight cases in six
meetings my colleagues are going to tell
you a little bit about what we do in
those meetings and talk to you a little
okay so thank you for the opportunity to
talk about the New Hampshire child
fatality Review Committee
as mentioned my name is Mark Clement
I'm a child psychologist a retired
maritai Colby Sawyer College faculty
member and I still teach part-time at
New England College
let me give you some background on child
fatality view teams
the New Hampshire child fatality Review
Committee was inaugurated by executive
order of Governor Judd Gregg in 1991.
the committee was restructured in 1996
by a subsequent executive order of
Governor Merrill
which placed the committee under the
auspices of the Department of Justice
where it remained until 2019 legislation
that which placed us under the
Department of Health and Human Services
now I've served as chair or co-chair
since that 1996 restructuring
the committee published and sent to
Governor Shaheen its first annual report
in October of 1998 and I know you have
our most recent annual report
now every state in the United States has
a child fatality Review Committee
they all function slightly differently
New Hampshire has a single team
most large states have multiple teams
like Massachusetts Michigan New York Etc
and an overarching State team
some teams only review child abuse bets
some have large budgets large staff
dedicated to just Child reviews child
fatality reviews
and there are multiple of other
differences so
there's a national Center for review and
prevention of child deaths based in
Washington D.C
they provide guidance educational
materials and National Data to the state
teams
but they have no control over our Review
Committee and how we operate okay we do
our work in ways that we feel our best
for the protection of children in New
Hampshire
my role today is to help you understand
how the committee does it works does its
work as mentioned there are five
objectives for the committee listed in
our legislation
and to synthesize them basically what
they say is that we are to review the
deaths of New Hampshire children
and generate recommendations that we
feel will reduce the probability of
children dying from these other causes
in the future
we have a committee of 28 highly placed
and highly highly qualified New
Hampshire professionals
who represent virtually every public and
private agency that is working with and
four children
our membership is designated in the
legislation
we meet every other month to review
child fatalities and to generate
recommendations
so I'm going to describe to you how a
typical meeting is organized and run
but before I do that I need to make
three General statements
first of all our major responsibility is
confidentiality
every member signs a confidentiality
agreement that prohibits them from
sharing any information that's discussed
in the review
any non-member who comes to the review
to present information for example a
police officer who might have
investigated that
also is required to sign a
confidentiality agreement
and I should add that our member
representative from the Attorney
General's office has been very
meticulous
in reminding and helping us with
confidentiality security
secondly we are not an investigative
body
we take information that is brought to
the committee by individuals or agencies
that have information to share about to
death
and lastly we do not review any death
that is presently in litigation or has
the possibility of future litigation
this is our guidance from the attorney
general
after all litigation and appeals have
we start each of our meetings in a
public session
or after some introductions and initial
business we have a presentation
regarding data and regulations that are
related to the types of deaths we're
reviewing
for example in reviewing suicide deaths
last year we had an individual from New
Hampshire state
Suicide Prevention that New Hampshire
State Suicide Prevention coordinator
come and give us a presentation about
suicide vests in the state of New
Hampshire
our last review a few weeks ago we
reviewed the death of children died in
fires we had members of the Fire
Marshal's Office do a presentation on
fire deaths in New Hampshire and fire
safety regulations
the purpose of these presentations that
everyone on the committee of where aware
of what the latest regulations and data
at that point after the presentation we
go into a non-public session and any
members of the public who are present
are asked to leave the room
information about the death is then
presented by any individual or agency
that has information
we typically start with law enforcement
then a chief medical officer
dcif if they have any information EMS
any routine or non-routine medical
information Behavioral Health
and then anyone else who has any
information from their agency
we then open it up to any questions that
members have about that information
once all the questions are answered and
all the information is presented we move
on to the recommendations part of the
review
and this is where
my co-chair our co-chair takes over
Dr Clement because some people have to
leave a chair calls on representative
Edwards with a question for you thank
you Mr chair I appreciate your
discretion and and I'm apologize in
advance for just jumping to the middle
right away
um uh I'm looking at page six uh
recommendation two
uh support health care provider
practices reviewing firearm safety at
well child visits and then the
implementation activity firearm safety
is reviewed as a routine part of
anticipatory guidance and Pediatric and
analysts and well care visits as per
Bright Futures guidelines I I just want
to share with you a very heated
conversation I had with the constituent
that was representative of other
constituents attitudes and they are
incensed when a doctor asks them the
status of firearms in their home they
don't think that's any of their business
it's not part of what the a typical
patient
physician relationship ought to be
and the the request was can you please
submit legislation barring the question
being asked and of course I said no
that's a First Amendment violation we
don't want the legislature crawling in
between the position and the patient but
I just I just want to know if this
second bullet implies that it's becoming
best practice among pediatric physicians
to make inquiries about the possession
yes
um
it is best practice because
um uh storing those Firearms safely is
is a best practice that reduces risk so
it's common I'm sorry to be interrupting
I just really do have to go oh yes but
but people who own firearms don't
typically go to their physician to ask
about how to safely maintain a firearm
it's it's anticipatory guidance for kids
for adolescents and children
okay I I just hope as you all roll this
out you remain extremely sensitive yes
that this is this is not an area where
people want their Physicians crawling up
inside their households so I do
understand the other side of it though
we don't want kids crawling around and
finding a gun and there being an
accidental shooting but but that's what
responsible gun ownership does yes and
if there is irresponsible gun ownership
then
those people aren't going to be
listening to The Physician given
guidelines anyways in most cases so so I
just I I if if this is a New Hampshire
Best practice that we're trying to roll
out and Implement I I just it would give
you a huge cautionary note
to the point I was just wondering
how many accidental uh what because I'm
I'm having a hard time just shoveling
through and finding the right chart I
know they're all in there I just haven't
found it yet
um could you just point us to the
statistics on uh that inform this as a
concern
so we know how many incidents we're
talking about
not many as director Tilly told you
about
um initially I mean New Hampshire's
child fatality
incidents is is fairly low okay the
intentional part of that is is suicide
most of which happen with Firearms
um okay including with teenagers uh
homicide
unintentional uh firearm deaths are very
rare okay thank you very much
yeah
I just wanted to be sure that there was
a a reason for that
issue being highlighted is it to this
point representative Murphy yes it is
you may speak no I was just going to
um point to the fact that on page 17 38
of all
um
intentional deaths are at the our
secondary to firearms and I I think that
that question that representative
Edwards brought up is in is important
but it's also to recognize also that in
all well child checkups in all pediatric
checkups they're not specifically only
asking about Firearms correct they're
asking one of the leading questions is
always if I'm you know and I've been
with my grandkids and my kids it is do
you feel safe at home
um and they're trying to probe their not
only their you know environment where
they live whether there's a gun
available or drugs available you know
there could be the same question they're
also just asking do they feel safe at
home so I think this is reasonable to
ask the question only because it is part
of the old the global question are you
safe at home and do you feel endangered
by any means by by virtue of yourself or
another person in the household yes and
that's what anticipatory guidance means
uh just asking a ton of questions about
um health and and environment and for
the record representative Murphy is Dr
Murphy so so you speak from experience
to this subject
yes but I was assuming I was speaking as
representative Murphy but with a
background in medicine so you may speak
out of both sides of your mouth we all
do I've done that often Mr chair yes sir
the question I was going to ask was
answered thank you
just wanted to be sure before I jumped
in okay well thank you um I also want to
thank you for the record the chair will
recognize people who wish to speak and
if the chair misses it which he often
does you can just sort of point and wave
I will not be offended well thank you
for for the guidance and the opportunity
um to discuss the commission's work as
as my co-chair mentioned I'm going to
talk a little bit about the process by
which we get to the recommendations that
you see in this report
um I think one of the things that I
didn't anticipate in my comments but I
will mention here just because it's part
of the discussion is that there's
probably many recommendations this group
would bring forward but the ones that
you see are related to the course in the
course of the time that we were together
in fiscal year 22. so while that um that
recommendation around anticipatory
guidance around firearm safety exists in
this report we've had previous ones
around swim safety around drowning all
part of the anticipatory guidance
component so there's a whole range of
Pediatricians
related well child care visit
checkpoints that we talk about I
understand that firearm safety sort of
jumps off the page in this particular
report but in previous reports you would
see things that were also related to
Accidental deaths as part of
anticipatory guidance that would show up
that would be additional topics so
you're seeing ones related to the cases
that we've talked about in this year but
it sits in in the scope of a broad range
of of items that we've brought forward
as recommendations as a committee so I
just wanted that to be in context
because I know it sort of feels like
there's a singular topic that's brought
out which is true because it's
reflective of the cases that we talked
about in this set of conversations but
if you looked at our history you'd see a
whole host of anticipatory guidance
related items and all of that comes from
the reality that when we review these
cases as Mark mentioned our goal is very
much to better understand the
circumstances of that case not because
obviously we can do anything about that
case but we want to understand how we
can learn from those cases for
additional recommendations for both
prevention and promotion of positive
activities the way that we do that is we
shape those conversations around risk
factors and protective factors
oftentimes despite the outcome of the
case there are lots of historical
components of a child's history that
bring forward some things that could be
protective and we want to highlight
those in addition to the risk factors
that that led to the outcomes that we're
seeing so um we talk about those
potential points of intervention to
prevent future child fatalities we
typically have a conversation about what
the risk factors were across the cases
that we've reviewed and what the
protective factors are and what you can
see is that within the specific
recommendations of the report
they often come into themes so many of
those themes are around increased
awareness that's often of resources and
services
what we have found in these reviews is
that there's often a lack of public
knowledge of some of the resources that
might be available to children into
families so we want to bring those
forward as much as we can and that
includes examples in these cases that we
reviewed around 988 as a mental health
service and distracted driving campaigns
so when we've talked about the motor
vehicle accidents and we've talked about
the suicides we've seen these um what
what our as Mark mentioned very
well-rounded set of organizations around
the able understand that there are
resources that may have been beneficial
to certain families in these cases I'm
trying to get information out to make
that awareness as great as possible
across the State Community Partners
again around resources that are
available to professionals that are
interfacing with the families as Mark
mentioned so you'll see a number of
recommendations
for our
better leveraging those Health Care
Professionals or those service
professionals to serve as dissemination
points of resources to families as well
there's a number of times that we talk
about just strengthening the systems of
care I know commissioner Weaver talked a
bit about the workforce shortages that
we have we certainly see that resonating
in the outcomes in some of these cases
where there's maybe services that could
have been available for folks but they
may have had trouble accessing those so
strengthening the systems of care comes
forward a number of times we also have
recommendations around processes and
procedures we've learned about how
sometimes the communication points
across the organizations that are
touching families maybe are not
communicating with each other and those
become potential points of intervention
and then we also have for our own work
in the work of of understanding child
fatality better you may also see some
recommendations around bettering for
collection of information that can serve
to inform our work and obviously the
work of reviewing fatality cases overall
so those are kind of the general themes
that I think that we we landed on in the
last couple of years of work I've only
been in the co-chair role since 2021 so
there's probably a whole host of work
before then that we could reflect on but
I'm not in the best position to talk
about that and then I just wanted to
mention and representative Edwards
mentioned it
sort of after their recommendations are
created out of this committee then we
work with the Department's team Lisa
who's here and Rhonda and others to
really think about how to implement
those recommendations so we what we
don't want to do is sort of end with
while this should be better and be done
with it at that point
um and so we've we meet and talk a
little bit about not only what should
the department be doing but honestly
there's a lot of um
a lot of commitment among the
organizations that sit around the table
to think about what their role could be
in helping to move some of these
recommendations forward so that could
include a recent conversation that we
had where a representative from the um
the hospitals indicated that they feel
like there's some training that could be
done in the ER staff so we're talking
with them about ways to potentially
bring that forward so that kind of
implementation work doesn't necessarily
get captured in the report because it's
a sort of multi-step project that
happens after that but certainly there's
a whole host of implementation
activities that come post those
recommendations coming out of the
committee
so with that I will I will stop because
I know we're short on time and answer
representative Murphy great thank you
very much Mr chairman um
this this sheet is great I mean it's got
a lot of detail and I haven't absorbed
any much of it yet but I I one thing
struck me is a couple things
on unintentional deaths in age 1 to 21.
poisoning with opioids was 38 that's a
huge number
if you look at the next page 17 and it
looks intentional you know suicide death
it's only one percent it's opioids so
that means these are this 38 I'm I'm
kind of curious as where did these where
do they where do they get the drugs now
is this drug is that school are on the
street or is this going through the
parents cabinets
um do you have that broken down as to
where they get those drugs in that 38
percent
so we don't have it uh broken down in
the report but poisoning you're right
does include overdose deaths we could
provide that information for you
um so follow me follow up so the reason
I ask that is I'm a kind of a
double-edged question here is what would
this have looked like say five years ago
you know that 38 was it 38 five years
ago in the other part the reason I asked
that is
if the children are getting their drugs
out of the out of the cabinet from
parents you know several years ago we
used the pain as the fifth Vital sign
and so we really were prescribing
heavily opioids and I'm wondering if
that's a residual of having a lot of
drugs in the house versus picking up in
the street I'm just trying to understand
where the opioid deaths in the use of
drugs come from Street versus home
most of the opioa deaths in teenagers do
not come from something that they found
in their parents right so they come they
come from either purchasing it illegally
that being said I don't know the
specifics I can tell you we uh in
maternal and child health have something
called the national violent death
Reporting System uh where we put
together all these uh factoids I do know
because I've been around a long time
that uh 10 15 years ago motor vehicle
crashes uh were number one and not
poisoning
um so there's been a very diff you know
definitive change
um in the last
10 15 years or so
and just one more follow-up and yeah
because I remember that 15 years ago
that was the leading cause was you know
trauma you know so in your chart says
ages 1 to 21 I understand the teenage
group but I'm just kind of wondering how
many of those are one to ten in is it at
a home that they get them and if I might
ask just one last question on page 14
you list under natural causes there are
two that are homicides and I'm just kind
of curious as how homicide gets into
I will have to find out that answer for
you I'm just curious thank you
representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman thank you all for
being here it's good to see those of you
who I already know again
um I was just wondering with respect to
the motor vehicle deaths has the
percentage changed I assume that the
percentage percentages changed because
uh opioid deaths have gone up but have
over that period of time motor vehicle
deaths gone down or are they staying the
same
if you know it depends upon the year
luckily in New Hampshire we're a very
small state so the numbers go up and
down motor vehicle deaths in particular
fatalities have gone down because of a
variety of reasons seat belt use
the very cool way that a Car Works to
keep you safe in the event of a crash
um
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question following up on
representative Murphy's question about
the
accidental
um suicides by opiate
I think it was two or three years ago we
passed the law that the pharmacist has
to put an orange label onto an opioid
when it's dispensed by the pharmacist
it'd be interesting to go back over time
to see if that's actually had an impact
on reducing
the Imp the rate if you will or whether
we're just putting something on the
sticker on the bottle but in reality
it's not really having an impact is
there a way for us to go back and look
at the timeline
um I don't know director Tilly
um the prescription drug monitoring
program is in our uh Division and I
don't know if that would be the most
appropriate uh
I am sorry representative Merchant I was
having a sidebar conversation while you
were asking your question if you could
repeat that for me thank you sure thank
you
two or three years ago we passed a law
that required the pharmacist to put an
orange sticker saying it's an opiate
onto the prescription that had an opiate
I would like to find out over time what
impact that's actually had on preventing
households the children getting into the
opiates or somehow looking at how that
law has truly impacted one way or the
other
how suicides possibly with children
occurring sure so I think we would have
to look at a couple of different data
sets as as Rhonda was saying we could
look at our pdmp and I'm sorry I can't
see you because there's a fan right in
the way I feel awkward about that but
um thank you thank you Mark
um so I think we'd have to look at a
couple data sets I'd have we'd have to
look at the pdmp so we'd see the rate of
those
um of those prescriptions the
um child fatality review could go a
little bit into the death report and
sort of understand is you know we look
at page 16 with those accidental deaths
and the poisoning of opioids you know we
can see that there was one case again
this is over several years 2017 to 21.
there was a case among a one to four
year old I think we can all be pretty
confident that the one to four year old
did not do that intentionally in any way
um and then we only had another case in
10 to 14 and then a handful of cases
among 15 to 18 year olds so I think we
would have to look at our two data sets
what's in the birth in the death record
we would also have to look at p DMP and
then I think there would have to be some
conjecture about how those two were
related I don't know that we can do a
direct correlation or a direct causation
from the orange label to a child getting
into it
I understood thank you I think at that
point in time if you can at least look
it over a timeline yes we can absolutely
can uh the administration or the
oversight of the Poison Control Center
is with also within MCH and our division
so we can ask oftentimes they're like uh
the canary in the coal mine and
um and so they also collect poisoning
stats and often the first ones both that
citizens and actually uh Pharmacists and
my mind turns to think synthetically and
I love to bring this this this and that
one or groups together for a group sink
uh yesterday I was talking with the
director of Motor Vehicles John marasco
about where do we go next in terms of
this card for Deaf motorists that was
developed in the New Hampshire
commission for the deaf and hard of
hearing
um
I could also see conversations with the
various gun groups in New Hampshire as
to how best we could encourage people
for safe gun storage that will at least
partially get the word out especially
whether our physicians who do not ask
this question of their children whether
they should or not they do not and it is
for reasons we can guess how can we
bridge the gap so my suggestion is as I
plod through
this wonderful detailed report I know
where my mind will go hey right here
this group should be talking with you
folks I would encourage that I find that
that that's works and I find that that's
probably in some ways already being done
yes yes yes absolutely I mean that's
really the power of this group is to
bring together those coalitions in your
note in the conversation around safe gun
ownership there's an example that we've
had in New Hampshire for a long time
around the gun shop project where gun
shops really took some looked at some
education and worked with folks around
Suicide Prevention in adults so there
and that is an example of where we've
taken folks from the public health world
and the medical world and you know
responsible gun owners to have a
conversation because no one wants to
have
um a suicide or an unintended death
that's related back to a particular
firearm
thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you so much
I've been texting various ones out there
to see if they wanted to bring us a few
things because we have the time and
um Paula minahan from the hospital
Association wants to talk to me about
some things afterwards and and that
includes Mr padmore that's afterwards
okay and uh did I see Henry lippman out
there yes I did not named Lori Mr
lippman come on up and say some things
about Medicaid because we will be
looking at that in the legislature this
term so I know it's off the cuff but you
have good cuffs so thank you sir you're
welcome
good morning for the record uh Henry
Lipman the Medicaid director director
l-i-p-m-a-n is how you spell my last
name
um
I think there are a couple things I've
been trying to bring to uh the attention
of the Committees of jurisdiction
um over the past week or so uh probably
most importantly where you might be
hearing from your constituents on is the
Consolidated Appropriations act that was
passed at the end of the year which
decouples the um continuous enrollment
from the public health emergency you
know declared federally we're starting
to notify
individuals first with a heads up letter
um that has gone out over the past week
or so to let them know that if they've
been in the protected status meaning
that
they haven't completed their
redetermination of Eligibility that they
run the risk of losing coverage
and on the the department had a meeting
with CMS to review our our unwind Clan
with with them and it was an informal
meeting we've got enough of an
indication that we're in the right place
with that and submitted our plan on the
first which was required in order for us
to start the unwind starting April 1st
they're about 102 000 individuals
today that are in that protected status
the largest group is our individuals in
the granite Advantage Program about 47
000 individuals there
the next largest group is actually
children a little over thirty five
thousand
in our unwind strategy and if I'm going
on too long please give me a signal but
if this isn't good information for you
but the
um the strategy that we're taking
because we have to spread the the
um
the review of Eligibility over uh nine
one ninth at uh one-ninth meaning
um of our total enrollment today which
is about 250 000 individuals we can only
do one-ninth of them
um per month and what we're trying to do
is look at first those individuals that
we've lost contact with and those
individuals who
um from a claims analysis have not used
services
and what we're really doing is a
risk-based strategy so that individuals
that for example we know are residing in
a nursing home or you know have
underlying medical conditions we're
going to allow ourselves more time to
get to those people so that we're not
you know my main goal is people who
should remain on coverage that we're
trying to do our best we can to make
sure that they do and those that aren't
going to be eligible to make them aware
of what their options are
um just last Friday
the federal government announced that
there'll be a special enrollment period
for individuals who are losing Medicaid
coverage and the fact they allow
um which is a little bit unusual before
they even lose coverage within the
60-day window before they lose coverage
they can sign up so there would be
potentially no break-in in health
coverage
so that's a there's a lot of work going
on behind that and I want to keep
um you know key stakeholders informed of
what's going on because I'm sure you'll
hear from constituents and you know if
we're missing something we want to hear
you know you may be a conduit to share
something for us to correct or to make
right
um the other
major initiative is we're coming towards
the 401 deadline of implementing the
adult dental program
we've made good progress there we
submitted all of our state plan
amendments and
waiver amendments that were required to
implement it as
required under legislation we believe
that we'll be through that process on
time you know my my only concern with I
think on that is you know with all
that's going on at the federal
government level would they potentially
fall behind with what they need to do
but you know I've reached out to the top
of uh of the chain of command there and
let them know that how important this is
and you know I've gotten an indication
they're going to help us get to the date
that we need to
we have entered into a contract
with Delta Dental who will be the
um the entity that will be providing the
um you know the biggest thing in front
of us is building out the network and
and that is you know over the next month
it'd be a good thing to report on um to
the next committee meeting because
that's sort of the key thing we're
working on it's it's not as far along as
I'd like to see it at this point but you
know we know that's the most important
thing to to to to get done
um
I think in terms of
um the other major bill that I think uh
you know on a forward-looking basis is
the reauthorization of uh of the Granite
Advantage Program which would otherwise
expire
um December 31st of this year
if there's not an action to to
reauthorize
today we're covering approximately a
little over 95 000 individuals on
granted Advantage
um
of those you know our forecast at this
point is probably by the time we do the
unwind it'll be closer to 64 000. we
began the pandemic at about uh
51 000 you know the granted Advantage is
a program that's basically an income
driven eligibility
and uh what we're seeing you know there
is I think that across the state that
you know the the beginning of the the
federal Public Health Emergency period
in March of 2020 that you know when
people there was a high
um sudden increase in unemployment that
you know many people
um were able to gain coverage this way
they're also good candidates potentially
to be able to move to the to the
marketplace
um
and um so I think that's that's that
topic
um if there's a particular area that
you'd like me to address I'd be happy to
yes thank you Mr chairman and also thank
you Mr lippman for the taking this
question I I met with a constituent just
this morning and he's uh very concerned
for his mother-in-law who
um had long-term Insurance long-term
care insurance and that didn't seem to
really do much for them and now Medicaid
is um telling them that they had to
actually cancel that policy which
they've now done and doesn't give them
many options they don't she has no money
and yet she can't actually be put into a
a home at this point because she hasn't
gone through all the qualifications on
where Medicaid is going to be
um what kind of advice do I have to give
to him
so I I think the best thing
um because these things can kind of get
complicated is if you
um share the the person who's uh
representing that this is a relative be
happy to have someone reach out and call
and try to help them sort it out you
know the process
um in New Hampshire
um one one piece of legislation that
didn't get through last year was one
where uh
it was part of a larger bill but today
we have to do asset verification for
going looking back to five years
sometimes when we're doing that process
we can see that maybe looking back three
years as an example that there's enough
information that you can make a
reasonable assertion I think there's
sort of a double edge here on the one
hand we're trying to protect the state
from paying for services that they
shouldn't on the other hand we're also
trying to protect the person to make
sure they're aware of what their
financial responsibility may or may not
be it's working with the
the team within the department you know
we're we're always here to try to help
people sometimes it's it's hard in terms
of being able to pull together financial
documents and the like that you know our
team's very willing to to to help so if
um
afterwards if um you don't have my phone
number I'll or email address I'll
provide that to you I do have it and
thank you and I will be reaching out
great thank you let me pick up on on
that very point on
um asset verification I know sometimes
on assistance programs always the
question of means testing comes up in
case somebody uh wonderfully gets an
employment that now they don't need the
program
um you were pointing out on the one hand
the responsibility to the state on the
other to the um uh the individual uh and
on granite Advantage do you means test
if so what is the way you do that so the
granted Advantage is purely an income
test is not a asset component to that
um and that's because of federal
um standards on that
um
but we
have mechanisms to be able to check
people's earnings that sign up into the
program generally self-employed a little
bit different situation but people have
a responsibility report or change in
circumstance
and if their income changes they would
potentially no longer be eligible and
that would be
um and I could just share with you that
um
foreign
New Hampshire never stopped doing
eligibility and
um and people who voluntarily did the
redeterminations but we since June we've
been able to get over 31 000 individuals
through our Outreach to complete their
redetermination on a voluntary basis and
that's an updated number from this
morning that I received and over 1700
people who we've reached out to have
told us
um we don't need Medicaid anymore we've
got another source of coverage so we've
been able to save the state money by
doing that Outreach and I think probably
by next week if I came in it'd be close
to 2000 from because we're working
lists where we might get a referral from
one of the MCO saying this is what they
said but we have to verify that
internally before we act on it
thank you both and I'm I'm thinking of a
couple of things that have come up to me
um as a follow-up to representative
King's question
obviously he has somebody's already in
difficulties but
um I've had several people come and and
ask
um
how they get qualified because they're
helping an elder or a friend or somebody
through the process
and I have uh offered a number of
suggestions which range from 211 to
service link to going down to the uh DC
the department office in Keene
do you have a preferred way or a way
that you know of that's the best for
somebody or is there does it depend
entirely on an individual circumstances
literally because I I you'll be glad to
know I I'd rather not refer everybody to
the commissioner's office so thank you
Chris santanello associate commissioner
Henry and I work really closely together
um for this I think honestly service
links right now
um would be the first choice just
because our staff are so busy right now
working on the online doing Outreach
making sure those that
are have continuous enrollment we get
through that second choice would be
coming to the district office
because lots of times if someone comes
to the district office our staff at the
front desk can answer questions provide
them information so I would say service
link or coming into the district office
okay thank you because I I will just
pass along that
um anecdotally service link is pretty
inundated as well I know and and I know
I'm not telling you anything you don't
already know I'm just reiterating
totally agree and again you can just
reach out to me and and may I ask
another couple
um I'm thinking of a fellow
representative and director he may have
reached out to you already but
um has constituents who are
ophthalmologists who take Medicaid and
very concerned because there are unpaid
invoices six months out and I'm
wondering what's happening with that so
A representative did alert me to that
and gave me the phone number to the the
practice in question
and I attempted to reach out to them I
understand they're away probably till
next week so we haven't made direct
contact yet but we'll certainly help
them out thank you and it you know it's
a concern because of course as you're
building out the dental networks I mean
providers are that take Medicaid or thin
thin on the ground and we want to keep
the ones who are providing the services
so
so generally there is a requirement that
we monitor in terms of timely payment of
claims and there are penalties if they
don't do that
um I think with that particular
circumstance with the information I have
that may be a little bit more to it than
there may well be and and I just want to
again
bring it up as a a concern because
generally
although it may be one specific set of
circumstances the the lack of providers
is nothing new as a concern to every
person in this room so thank you very
much
chairman McDonald
thank you Mr chairman this is just a
knowledge update a question for myself
uh service link did that take the place
of New Hampshire easy
no we still have New Hampshire easy so
service link
um and I was actually as as before I um
you asked the question I was thinking I
should have said sir New Hampshire easy
as well
um but yes we still have New Hampshire I
was wondering okay thank you very much
few questions for me picking up on
previous questions I think most of you
know I am part-time CEO of a faith-based
wellness center in Kingston and taking
medicaid patients is part of what we
want to do I also have to pay our bills
and I'm wondering when we will see a
good increase in what providers receive
for taking medicaid people by my family
practitioners
so the department and the agency budget
phase made requests there's also a
number of bills the largest of which I
think was written up in the news this
this week Senate Bill 86 which
proposes to add
145 million in rate increases over the
biennium and the first hearing on that
you're throwing it back to me and I'll
take it yeah sure I think this this is
one of the
um major issues that I'm sure that this
legislature will have to deal with this
session is how to you know that we're
sort of I kind of look at where we're at
a little bit like uh the pressure
building on up on a dam that has a leak
in how much can can it be held back and
that has to be worked sort of through
I recently had a chat with uh Tom Rafael
from Delta Dental and I said how's it
going because as you know I was one who
took point on the floor of the house on
the dental bill and thank you thinking
that it would please God by 10 and it
passed by 90 something so there's hope
going forward on some of this other
stuff I think I'm doing my work but he
pointed out that oh it's all well and
good to have the money available but you
need dentists who will do it how we
doing on getting dentists to take people
under the dental program so
um that's I think one of our still one
of our key challenges for April 1st
we're working just before this meeting I
was meeting with people about that and
I'm going to be meeting with probably
Tom Rafael next week in terms of and
what we can do to to build that we are
having some successes but we're not
where we need to be yet
um you know just going back to the rate
increase if I could talk about about
that for a moment last session you did
pass rate increases and maybe just
remind some of the key ones is
ambulances which we're seeing some
challenges you may hear from
constituents about transferring patients
between hospitals or between nursing
homes and hospitals those that
increase that brought New Hampshire's
ambulance rates from 25 percent to 50
percent of Medicare
still I think an area of concern from
from an access standpoint to me as the
Medicaid director we also added 25
percent
to maternity care delivered at hospitals
it was a the 25 percent was the average
we were able to increase the rates at
critical access hospitals that still do
maternity by 34 and 24 at the larger
hospitals
um and uh
in terms of other kind of rate increases
that um
off the top of my head those are two
that that uh comes to mind but there are
probably a couple others that and
are there plans afoot uh within the
department I know they're trying to hire
in
the medical facility I look after we
have been partially paying students
tuitions with loan forgiveness or
tuition forgiveness as they work for us
that is putting another step on a tall
ladder that they can negotiate I also
know Rockingham County nursing home
because that's my legislative
responsibility as part of the delegation
we are doing similar what could we do
perhaps is there plan are there plans
afoot oh for example to help somebody in
a dental school in exchange for to come
here to help with this population
we do um and Trisha Tilly's probably
knows more about this than I do but
within Public Health we have
um
loan forgiveness program a loan
repayment programs
um that are available
um in addition we have been trying to
help the County nursing facilities all
through the federal Public Health
Emergency we've been passing on the
extra Federal matching percentage
directly to the uh to the nursing
accounting nursing facilities uh in the
form of their Pro share payments and in
terms of the county cap calculations
helping out the the counties with their
their obligations as well and it's been
a fairly sizable number as it's gone on
for almost three years just one
anecdotal footnote there that the
Consolidated appropriation act uh
carries the enhanced Federal match
through March 31st at 6.2 percent then
is reduced
um a quarter at a time from 6.2 to 5 to
2 and a half to one and a half where the
enhanced death map ends the end of this
calendar year
director Tilly
how are we going to make this better and
bigger
thank you so much chair so um as Henry
noted we have our state loan repayment
program and and specifically around
dental we've also expanded it this year
to private dentists who take Medicaid
clients that was a huge lift for us as
opposed to in the past we really had
dentists that were in our federally
qualified health centers or were that
working in one of those types of
facilities but to expand it to private
has been a big deal and we've had uptake
good uptake over it over this past year
we've been using arpa funds those funds
will go away at some point so that's
certainly a conversation for another
biennium to have but we have been very
fortunate to have arpa funds and some
general funds to provide that loan
repayment and the other piece is we also
have a recruitment contract where we're
going out and recruiting like crazy
I know that there's underserved areas
but there are underserved people groups
within a well-served area are we
improving the underserved people in
non-underserved areas yes absolutely and
that's what we look at you know I mean
it's a it's a twofer so there's you know
and we have a whole bit of alphabet soup
as many of you know of hearses and and I
mean in hipses and dipses and mipses
which are health professional shortage
areas but we also look at those specific
populations and you know primarily of
them are are low income and so that's
where Henry's work and my work always
intersect that we're always trying to
make sure that we have access for those
who have Medicaid and especially now as
we're looking at the new adult Dental
benefit
you're speaking all of these terms made
me very grateful my mom fed me alphabet
soup as a child representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman
director thank you so much for uh
sitting in the hot seat unannounced and
without any preparation uh obviously
interested him ahead of time
I appreciate that and obviously it's a
Hot Topic it might you brought up the
question of stratification I certainly
appreciate uh that you can only do
one-ninth of the population at risk
right now at a time but certainly you
know risk stratification as to who will
fall off the cliff first and need it and
I was wondering where what sort of data
you use to determine that is it simply
their age do you have access to their
employment currently do you have access
to their current health record that they
may have a need I was just kind of
curious as to where you had that uh
where that data came from us so we look
at their categorical eligibility so for
example someone who's in CFI the you
know choices for Independence or
long-term care or children
um but you know those are generally the
vulnerable groups and we early on the
process we did a lot of Outreach to
those and fortunately those are other
than the children group is
um you know smaller very it's sort of a
smaller population then we added the
dimension of looking at claims
um that we had as to whether
um they and we basically used a dollar
stratification to look at if they had
zero claims over the past year that
suggests they're probably lower risk not
an absolute none of this is you know a
perfect science and then we looked at
you know certain conditions like someone
who might have hemophilia as an example
that you know going without coverage
could be a pretty serious to their life
situation then we looked at
um you know large people who used a lot
of Health Care as being someone that we
want to actually do maybe some personal
Outreach either directly through
Department staff or through our mcos so
you know a lot of states are just doing
it like uh last in I mean first in first
out and you know we're trying to be more
sensitive to it and I'm proud of that
that we're we're making it that way and
just a quick follow-up is if you follow
up yes thank you
um so given a circumstance say somebody
this year in 23 is just about to turn 65
say in December is there any but they're
going to go off the cliff in April they
run is there any way that they can move
up their eligibility date for Medicare
is that coordinated in that way at all
to help them bridge that yeah they're
actually uh thank you for the question
there are actually people who are should
be on Medicare that aren't there yet and
those are another sort of group that we
want to work with carefully
um and um
I think that there are people who are
could potentially be dual eligible
before we actually let someone off the
plan we have to run them through our
what we call our Cascade to see if
they're eligible for something else and
um so that uh
you know I I know as as much as we're
planning and we've been planning for
this for since July of 2020 on a weekly
basis that we're going to need your
antenna to you know because it won't be
perfect
um in the sense that you don't people's
circumstances change and and if we can
help someone we want to be able to do
that so appreciate it thank you for the
effort
please keep me updated particularly on
the dental thing you know that's
important to me and we'll see you next
month absolutely I did want to mention
on the same Senate Bill 86 there are
Provisions in there that um deal with
also uh trying to support the
availability of
Workforce so that's a bill you might
want to take a look at if based on your
questions you have given me my weekend
homework assignment sir thank you you're
welcome thank you
well there we are and usually at the end
we have an encore presentation from John
Williams
nobody got that
thank you so um we're trying not to
encourage you too much
so chairman Pearson if it uh is the
pleasure of this committee you have had
uh as you're standing operating
procedure and it's worked out fairly
well
um as it relates to scheduling and
avoiding conflicts with the fiscal
committee to meeting on the fourth
Friday of the month and the meetings uh
typically start at 10 in the morning if
there is a conflict that does arise that
this group meets at one in the afternoon
seems to be a good process good system
so if that's something for your
consideration you'd like to continue
that would mean the next regular meeting
of this committee would be tentatively
Friday February 24th at 10. can you tell
us what's on the agenda
tentatively on the agenda which is
driven by various statutory and chapter
law reporting requirements would include
um well I'll start one with one that is
neither of those very important however
is the update from our commissioner our
interim commissioner Lori Weaver as
she'd mentioned she'll be able to
provide more details around the roadmap
and other updates that are critical for
this committee to here in addition to
that tentatively we have under Senate
Bill 147 from 2021 a final report on the
spend down requirements our agency has
conducted educational opportunities
within our agency for those Frontline
workers to be
better educated for uniformed
application of the spend under
requirement particularly as it relates
to mental health delivery of services
you had an interim report uh Karen
Hebert our division director I know
Hebert our division director and also
Don Tierney formerly Landry were the
ones who presented I would expect that
they would be presenting as well for
their final report in addition to that
there is also a statutorily driven
report under RSA 128 11 that falls under
the health officer statutes for an
annual report from the health officers
again these are tentative and also
subject to additional items from through
your chair through you through the chair
for items that this committee might have
a particular interest in
thank you very much if the committee
would like to hear something that is not
on the tentative agenda please let me
know as soon as possible so we can line
up the uh people to speak I want to give
the committee an update before we close
last fall I formed two special
subcommittees one was on emerging
medical Technologies let me give you
very briefly the history of that
the late and much beloved Catherine
Rogers sent a bill to Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs committee
on that broad topic
representative soloway
convinced us it would be the best thing
to send it here
it could happen faster
and to send it to this committee and
form a subcommittee and come up with a
report and go from there and
representative soloway did this I
appointed a subcommittee that he chaired
they
um came up with a report
and that report turned into a bill and
we will be looking at the emerging
medical Technologies Bill uh very soon
so that's the update on that that's the
story
I don't I'm sorry
you know I don't know details but I
think it's coming to your committee
okay great
the other one representative Solway has
a family member who works for the i-team
Spotlight team of the Boston Globe and
gave me a heads up about
front page continued inside on four
complete pages that a particular surgeon
in New Hampshire
his malpractice company has settled 20
malpractice cases against him
and that was reported on the website of
the Massachusetts Board of Medicine but
was not reported on the website of the
New Hampshire Board of Medicine even
though that surgeon practiced here
and so representative soloing again
um retired epidemiologist retired member
of Health and Human Services elderly
Affairs committee retired member of this
group suggested a subcommittee which he
insisted I chair on the issue of
transparency at the New Hampshire Board
of Medicine that subcommittee met on
October 3rd 17th and 31st we had lots of
people on board some of them I'm looking
at we took testimony and we came up with
a couple of tentative conclusions
one was that perhaps
there needs to be some changes in the
protocol as to what gets reported on the
website it may well be the case that the
New Hampshire Board of Medicine did
nothing wrong they were operating under
different rules than the board in
Massachusetts operates under but we
don't know that and what we are looking
at is should the rules be continued or
should they be changed the second
conclusion we came up with is that the
Board of Medicine has a retired
part-time
volunteer physician investigating and
perhaps there could be
greater Staffing of this when complaints
are made this is no fault of the one
who's doing it on his own dime this is
simply saying there may need to be more
uh representative ulery filed a bill I
was co-sponsor of it it was heard by
Edna that some funds at oplc office of
professional licensure and certification
all of the funds they receive from
licenses after their expenses all the
leftover money goes into the general
fund could some of that be non-lapsing
that is to say they get to keep some so
that they seeing a need could have
already hired additional staff does that
have to wait for the next budget cycle
that Bill's been heard in Eda and will
come to the floor
where I wish to go forward with this
transparency yes there is a bill that
will re-establish basically the
subcommittee it will look at rules and
regulations it will also periodically
oversee Board of Medicine to make sure
the rules are being followed that's a
bill that will be coming up in health
and human services and I'm Prime sponsor
while that is running its slow course
along the way to being established
probably over the summer late fall I
will be pulling together just as an
individual I'm not convinced yet that I
want to establish another subcommittee
but I do want to have some conversations
so should the bill establishing a Board
of Medicine oversight committee be
passed and signed into law we a lot of
the work in that group will already have
been done so that's just an update on
those two subcommittees and boy I misrep
misrepresentative Solway yes
representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman for uh representative Weber the
first build the medical Technologies is
323 and the second Bill the one on the
board of medicine is 322 and they're
both being presented next Wednesday
in health and human services oh see you
there thank you and now we all know who
has read the calendar and who has not
well I was well I worked with our
chairman on those two so
I was interested
anybody else on the committee anything
else
Representatives I just wanted to point
out that doesn't mean I'm disinterested
I'm just lagging behind
we have each other's backs that's how we
work here
okay good thank you see you uh
I'm going to pick out a turn at the
beginning
oh that's a reflection
s
um
[Music]